[Music]
clothes is the new Netflix thriller
movie based on real-life bodyguard
Jackie Davis who protected the likes of
JK Rowling and Nicole Kidman and the
royal family whilst the film deals with
completely fictional characters and
events they aren't too far removed from
the reality that Davis dealt with across
a 30-year career in the profession
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about the ending of clothes as well as
some of the real-life situations that
Jackie herself went through there will
of course be heavy spoilers here so if
you don't want to know anything about
the film or its ending then I highly
suggest that you turn off now but for
everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I watch it so you don't
have to we follow Sam a close Protection
Officer as she is tasked with guarding
Zoey Tanner Zoey is the heiress to a
multinational corporation named Hasson
mining and this throws her in to blows
with her stepmother Rima whose family
founded the company in the absence of
her father Zoey is legally now the
majority owner of her scene but once
very little to do with the running of
the company or its dealings her father
only left her the controlling shares in
the hope that her and reamer would
become closer in the wake of his death
thus Zoey is flown out to Casablanca and
put into a state-of-the-art safe house
whilst has seen mining competes with a
company called C Kong in an attempt to
secure a contract for a large piece of
land that is rich in phosphate she is
assigned Sam as a bodyguard who's picked
solely for the fact that she is a woman
and that Zoey will not be able to sleep
with her like she did with her
predecessor however things go awry when
the safe house is attacked by kidnappers
who are attempting to secure a ransom
for the girl Zoey and Sam make it out of
the situation as the sole survivors do
to sam's skill and all seems like the
worst may be behind them when they
manage to make it to a police escort
this escort turns out to be a group of
corrupt cops who too want the ransom on
Zoe's head and the duo only managed to
make it out of the situation because
Zoey murders a policeman this
immediately makes her a fugitive and
liquidate her shares meaning that Rima
who disowns her stepdaughter live on air
is now back in control Sam reaches out
to an ally to help her escort though II
out of the con
this brings back memories of it author
as it seems like Sam is going above and
beyond the call of duty in order to
protect Zoey
unfortunately Sam's Ally is killed in
another botched kidnapping attempt that
almost cost Sam her life the two managed
to escape and using a taxi returned to
Reimer to see her meeting with one of
the kidnappers we eventually learn is a
policeman working the investigation
after all of the signs point to reamer
being behind the kidnapping the two
returned to the safe house in order to
hack Reema's phone when the kidnappers
and Rima arrived separately it seems
that they are working in tandem together
until we learn that it's actually Zeke
on who were behind the attacks after
busting some amazing hacker man skills
salmon Zoey managed to take down the
corrupt policeman and assassins behind
the kidnapping plot and reunite with
dreamer Sam makes a promise to Zoe to
finally call her daughter who learned
had been given up for adoption at due to
Sam being a teenage mother this
highlights the themes of the film which
center around estranged mothers and
daughters reuniting to find their
kinship just in the same way that Sam
now wants to repair her relationship
with her child Reema and Zoe too want to
rebuild theirs it's a touching motif
that highlights just how much of those
we don't think care actually do even
though both Sam and Reema was strict on
Zoe which led her to believe that they
disliked her she realizes that it was in
fact for her own good in order to keep
her safe Sam realizes that her daughter
will not be in danger because of her
work any longer and returns to
civilization with the hope that they may
once again find each other in real life
Jackie who Sam was based on actually
began her career as a policewoman in the
1970s however after becoming frustrated
with the low pay in the sector she
switched career paths while she
initially faced ridicule amongst the
males in her profession she eventually
gained their respect due to the
dangerous situations she was able to act
through throughout her career Jackie has
been shot at stabbed and thrown through
a window over the air she's protected
the likes of Justin Beiber Diana Ross
the Beckham's and many more she states
that though she get to travel the world
visiting luxurious locations it's a
stressful job that goes far beyond
stopping fans from grabbing selfies
jackie has had to stop violent gangs who
want to kidnap and burgle celebrities
and in the case of her protection of
Katie Price this happened and Jackie was
required to act fast under pressure like
several of the scenes we see in the film
she also broke into a villa in Kashmir
to rescue a 23 year old female kidnap
victim and this put her in the
crosshairs several times
Jackie herself worked as a consultant on
the film and it's clear that a lot of
the heart-pounding action that takes
place in it is from her real-life
experiences
so what did you think of close and what
did you take from its ending comment
below and let me know and if you enjoy
this video then please like it and make
sure you check out my breakdown of this
week's other big Netflix release the
punisher which will be linked at the end
this is a channel for people who are mad
into movies so that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe thanks again for
taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]